vous lisez votre plan à de faire ce que
vous faites là bien sûr au simplon
présent je me suis dit je vous les
journalistes voilà mai mais en
l'occurrence ya plein de gens pour qui
ce métier là c'est viscéral à l'essai
dans les tripes et ils peuvent pas faire
autrement parce que c'est vraiment c'est
un besoin dans une nécessité qu'elle
convoite ont plombé ses thèmes sportifs
alors exactement je veux du basket ou
mary 1,94
ça y est grand souci de griffes sap
lancer le sien moi quoi vous c'était
quoi lancer c'est qu'on vote pour en
rappelant qu à faire quoi la base un
plan de formule un pilote de formule un
même plan b comédiens d'accord dans ses
buts ou mieux comme les deux peuples se
lancer la télé blanc c'est la télé est
impensable
[Rires]
du coup c'est ça m'a bien aux gens c'est
comme c'était quoi vous votre après
troubadours voilà c'est je me suis marié
parce que je voulais pas bosser je
voulais pas me manque la vie banale
oui et non pénale prudente mais vous
c'est exactement ça j'en ai laisse en
plan à magicien en plan b est en plan
ses producteurs de spectacles n'ont
finalement je les réalise au fur et à
mesure heureusement y'a pas animateur en
réalité c'était comédien je voulais
vraiment être comédien recherche et
section de recherches
ouais et aïcha non mais j'ai vu que je
suis pas au top de la de la crise est
aussi une chance
comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
aïcha écoute alors et donc oui non
c'était une série pour france 2 de
yamina benguigui qui est une série qui
va d'ailleurs reprendre sans doute donc
voilà donc j'ai fait cette section de
recherches qui a apprécié votre flore
alors être comédien oui sept comédiens
mais plombé la télé est arrivé par
hasard mais j'étais plutôt journalistes
au départ oui d'accord et puis mon
premier métier c'est huissier de justice
quand ben oui danse pas vrai cette
justice et non moi à merde dans les
oreilles parce que vous l'auriez plus
quoi cette menace était du droit j'ai
fait quand on est jeune on sait pas trop
ce qu'on veut faire la même loi par
dessus il ya 40 ans donc c'est vrai oui
oui mais non j'étais vicié oui 6,50
droite tout le reste de travers
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais alors cette émission parfois vous
êtes tranquille vous avez un truc qui
vous arrive dans la gueule c'est moi
c'est quoi votre plan b vous agathe et
droit d'ailleurs moi je suis très bien
dans ce plan là mais sinon j'aurais bien
voulu être provenant des noms ou
heynckes ex bientôt me coûte au new
hampshire
c'est étonnant parce que des vous parlez
anglais vous monter d'un cran dans les
draps je sais quand je vire les gens
aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pascal c'est déjà un plan b la tête
puisque c'est quoi votre métier plein
plan à moi je vais prof de sport c'est
bon ouais je suis encore dans sport
effectivement plan b c'était par hasard
voilà télé mais s'étaient élevées dans
le ça m'était conté pour lancer tmp et
plan dit appelant dé prendre ta place tu
veux je te dise franchement si tu es bon
mois ce sera le second qui changeait la
marge
c'était quoi ton plombé bon moi je
voulais vétérinaires n'ont pas le bac
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les animaux quand ton animal préféré
j'aime beaucoup les chiens d'accord j'ai
un nouveau chien d'ailleurs s'appelle
s'appelle na na nana na na na à la toile
est neuf et tout est sauvage oui mais
c'est un gars là n'a jamais j'avais
choisi bella mais après j'ai pensé à
kelly kelly ja j'ai changé un opus à
sakho vous appeliez médaille à kanye
west
[Applaudissements]
regardez tous les bleus voilà et ballet
de 1 phrase vous le donne à l'est ils
ont pris elle-même joue pas on s'en fout
car vous êtes très bien on peut envoyer
ça j'ai adoré à wigan et chemise en fond
d'écran vous c'était vous êtes mannequin
ouais c'est vrai mon bled à ces artistes
lambert à la scène politique et plan
c'est sauver les animaux et les safaris
solitude les châtiments ils sont encore
émissions de suie l'épongé dès scully en
fait alain à vous les mangez des fruits
biscuits en fait à la base des animaux
et des enfants et des femmes et des
enfants
willan enfants alexander wolf a besoin
alexander alexander mon amour tu aimes
ça me posait aucun problème
vous savez j'ai un grand coeur dans une
tour des personnes c'est la même chose
que toi tu aimes les filles oui bah
projets pour aider mais les mecquois les
filles et fils herbert s'en faut une
fille bien mais kane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mieux renseignés que ça là
maintenant il est très mignon hashtag
puceau
[Musique]
on se calme on joue lille a beaucoup de
succès je les ai vus avec des meufs albi
pour ça non non non non non non non non
franchement je t'ai vue gameplay mais où
ça s'est vu dans mes pas vu pas du tout
d'accord ok au téléphone j'ai entendu
des baffes à côté à dans l'électro de
dire comme ça c'est le